[Musique]
s'il y a une chose dont je gagnais
convaincu c'est qu'il ne votera pas pour
justin trudeau le 21 octobre bien les
albertains le travailleur en
construction maintenant à la retraite
déteste profondément libéraux un dégoût
qui remonte aux années 80 puis 1,82 à
arrêter quand gbagbo n'avait plus dans
tout et d'alberto ex-mari banqueroute à
cause de pierre trudeau parce que y
arriver avec le programme d'énergie
nationale où es tu avec ce programme
pierre-elliot-trudeau à leur premier
ministre canadien veut contrer la montée
en flèche du prix des hydrocarbures
on est en pleine crise pétrolière
mondiale les politiciens force l'alberta
à vendre son pétrole arabe et pour aider
les consommateurs dans l'est du pays
les three day and paul alberto royaume
paul wef quarante ans plus tard la
méfiance envers les libéraux ne s'est
pas envolée geslin partisans
conservateurs reprochent même à justin
trudeau l'achat du pipeline trans
mountain pensez vraiment que ottawa a
dépensé quatre milliards et demi de
dollars pour ne pas qu'il soit construit
oui mais c'est toute la logique là
dedans ah y'a rien n'y a rien de magique
avec trudeau
[Musique]
à calgary la candidate libérale justin
est habitué d'entendre ce genre de
commentaires qui évoque la théorie du
complot
sans coopération s'est elle a beau faire
campagne avec un chien adorable elle
n'est pas toujours bien accueilli par
les électeurs le commentaire de jean
steen pour surprendre mais il fait
partie de sa stratégie
plutôt que de parler de son chef elle
met de l'avant sa candidature si pas
nécessairement quelque chose de gagnant
quand vous commencez en disant bonjour
je suis la candidate de justin trudeau
fois ici joe reinstein crois quand même
en ses chances de l'emporter
selon ce politologue le risque est bien
réel
les albertains se retrouve sans
représentant dans un éventuel
gouvernement libéral ça entraînerait de
grands défis de gouvernance et sa
alimenterait le sentiment d'aliénation
dans l'ouest selon lui les libéraux ont
perdu beaucoup de points en alberta en
adoptant le projet de loi ses 69
ils resserrent les évaluations
environnementales iran la construction
d'oléoducs plus difficile sur go sport
pour bien des albertains
ce projet de loi est la preuve que
justin trudeau n'est pas vraiment
propice
si les environnementalistes critique le
bilan climatique de justin trudeau
beaucoup d'albertains lui reproche de ne
pas avoir défendu plus fermement secteur
pétrolier
comme quoi gouverner au centre vouloir
marier économie et environnement est un
couteau à double tranchant
ici l'heure enfin radio canada dans la
région de calgary